bismillah al hamdulillah I greet you
with the greeting of all the messages of
God including one of the mightiest
messengers that was ever sent of the
five Jesus peace be upon him he greeted
his followers with this greeting the
greeting of the Angels the greeting of
the prophets and that's the greeting
we're greeting you with here today peace
be unto you and if that's too much for
you hey what's up how you doing thank
you for tuning in to the Dean show and
we get to interview people who have
accepted this wonderful way of life the
call to acquire peace by submitting to
the owner piece the one God the creator
of the heavens and earth so people from
all walks of life are racing to Islam
the rich the poor the famous Bible
scholars Christian scholars that are
going up higher up I have had a chance
to interview people who have finished
with master's degrees finishing seminary
schools they're coming to Islam what's
going on this is a phenomena they're
seeing that all the evidence is pointing
to Islam being the truth and it provides
all the proof that is not a man-made a
religion but indeed it is organized by
the one God who created this whole
universe and everything in it who's not
a man or a woman but he's a crater of
man and woman now when we come back
there are also some people who are born
with the title Muslim but it's not
because default now you're born with
parents who are Muslim that you now are
chosen by God and you just going to
enter paradise you have to come to a
conscious decision at one point in your
life just like the person who's born in
a Christian family this person is born
in a Jewish family Hindu family whatever
kind of family you have to come to a
conscious decision that you know what I
want to submit not to my desires but to
the one who created me and my next guest
when we come back brother Omar is going
to talk about how he made that decision
coming from a family of Muslims who are
practicing and him being a young man who
decided to practice this beautiful way
of life Islam when we come back here in
the Dean show stay tuned
I love there's only one word Muhammad is
His Messenger a la la
ah ha there's only one but Jesus was his
messenger Allah why did that may be it
may be a victory does it elmar how are
you doing I'm gonna greet you with those
same greeting I greeted everybody with a
minute ago Salaam alaikum well I come
salamat a peace be with you my brother
peace be with you as well now this is a
unique show now because we get a lot of
converts people who are of other faiths
they were followers of the Christian
faith of the Hindu faith of the Jewish
faith whatever faith and then they come
to a conscious decision so you know what
things are making sense here there are
some contradictions here you know what
the proof is not adding up and then they
look into Islam and they say you know
what this is where it's at there's a
book has been unchanged untampered with
the verbatim would have got the Quran
some come to it with all would have
analytical approach scientific progeny
see all these beautiful and wonderful
miracles in the Quran and then they
submit so those are the stories of those
people but now you you have a father
who's Muslim is that right that's right
and a mother who's Muslim try but you
weren't always practicing it seems like
just a year ago so we want to get a
little bit of your history how did you
come to where you're at today tell us a
little bit about you so where you're
from and what you're doing who you are
well my name is Omar first of all now I
grew up in Chicago so you know I have a
very similar history to anyone who's
living in Chicago you know I'm not into
a super rich family not a super poor
family you know classes so just another
guy yeah middle-class you know middle
class and with parents and family who
doesn't really practice its thumb it's
you know it's always been I always knew
I was Muslim but I never really knew why
you know we have a lot of people who are
born into faiths but they only because
they call themselves this because their
parents are that you know there are a
Christian because their parents are a
Christian there behan do because their
followers a Hindu and in Islam we have
the same problem we have people who are
Muslim because they their fathers are
Muslim you know and that is a problem
because you get people who then
represent the true Muslims who don't
really know much you know they don't
really know what their religion preaches
or the basic theology of their religion
and so the way I really for me you know
a lot of people when they come to a
faith they kind of have maybe it's in a
tragedy they lose a family member or
some big thing and then they have only
God right they had nothing else to turn
to with me it was actually quite the
opposite because I in fact was very
happy the wife I had I had no reason to
I didn't need God you know I had
everything I had my own apartment I had
a car i had women i had everything you
know so I had what age is this this is
when I first got into college so I'm 18
years old now cut the college some
people just go for the experience now
this is where you know some people just
go for the experience will get away from
the family and now they just let loose
yes and that's what was about to happen
to me okay because you know I had
roommates and roommates influence you
you know in a lot of things and one
thing they wanted me to do you know
let's go to the club let's go to the
bars let's go meet these women right
bringing women into my apartment all the
time and I was always kind of saying no
but they got to the point where I'm like
well wait a minute why why am I saying
no because I'm a Muslim why am I am
Muslim you know you're starting to crowd
right right why why should I keep
following these rules when I could be
doing this you know and so did some some
did your family instill some of the good
Islamic yeah yeah yes because those
right on you because we my family
doesn't drink they don't smoke they
don't eat pork things like this you know
basic I mean I don't come from a bad
family don't get me wrong yeah but they
nothing was ever pushed you know I
wasn't really given I was never given a
reason not to do things I was just told
this is we don't do it so don't do it
you know and I kind of went along with
the flow but when you get to be when you
get to be 18 to go to college things
change and you kind of I mean for any
person I think you're kind of question
you question why am i living the way my
parents told me to live why why am I not
drinking one right already why am I not
chasing girls right exactly and and
these things were all readily available
to me you know i don't have to go and
find them and so I thought well let me
just look into Islam here but I didn't
look into it trying to find a reason to
believe I looked into it trying to find
a reason for it to all be nonsense so
then you can go ahead right right all
right you're right the front right to
the club exactly so I'm trying to find a
reason why I can say look there it's all
fake now I can go with my friends right
yeah and but I think I mean I'm also I
like to think of myself as being a
sincere person you know an honest person
and when when i read about i'm a man of
science first of all i don't believe in
anything superstitious I don't do I
don't cross my fingers to be lucky you
know I don't do any of this kind of
stuff if I don't see it I'm not going to
believe it this is not how I work yes
and so I thought if there's going to be
a real religion you know if there's
going to be a god the proof of this God
has to be extremely obvious right i mean
he's what kind of I mean the very nature
of God and she's merciful he's loving
what kind of God is merciful loving but
then says well maybe I zist maybe I
don't you know doesn't give any clear
evidence this is kind of a contradiction
in and of itself mm-hmm so I I'm not
going to believe something that's not
obvious I'm knocking if it's not clear
and if it doesn't hit me over the head
with just sheer obvious pneus I'm not
going to believe it you know and I'm a
man of science so when I first was
looking into the Quran you know this
holy book that we Muslims seem to be
following I'm asking people you know
what makes this book so amazing why why
is his book different than the Bible you
know or the Torah or anything else and a
lot of what I was hearing was the
linguistic miracle right the way it's
written well I don't speak Arabic so
that's I didn't look into that very much
the other thing I kept hearing was
the scientific facts in the Quran that
no one could have known at the time of
the prophet and so I thought you know
okay what what are these facts you know
what you know what how what can be in
this book that was not known at the time
yes and I'm telling you Eddie when you
when you look at what's written written
in the Quran I mean you put all the
other miracles miracles aside the
prophecy that's come true the way it's
written that I've now come to understand
you just look at the scientific facts
when it describes in clear detail the
formation of the embryo Mohammed could
not have known these facts about human
development in the seventh century
because most of them were not discovered
until the 20th century when it says the
earth is the shape of an ostrich egg you
know I mean I read that and I thought
you know why did why that's how the
earth is shaped you know it's not just
circle there's a unique shape to the
herb that matches in oestrogen right
right and you know this is something at
the time of the Prophet you know peace
be upon him we have to remember everyone
is thinking the earth is flat yeah all
of a sudden now this guy says no no it's
actually not flat not only does he say
it's not flat he says it's shaped like
an ostrich egg you know out of all the
eggs to choose he could have picked a
chicken egg you know he could have
picked a fish egg why does he pick an
ostrich egg you know so this is that
shape how it's designed that the look if
you would compare it right to a tennis
ball or to a football or to an ostrich
egg this is how it would resemble more
so and this is what you're seeing now
and this is what this is what is in the
Quran you know 1400 years ago I mean
this and this is just one of the you
know who who could have known that first
of all who could have known that some
say okay the prophet he maybe he's
really smart maybe he was an astronomer
me maybe he figured it out or maybe he
was just lucky right yeah okay fine
that's just one thing what about the
hundreds of others you know what about
the the formation of the embryo what
about the water cycle you know all these
things that are written and not you know
not just
they don't they're not just talked about
in broad you know sense i mean detailed
I mean these are these are things that
most modern scientists who when they see
it they have no choice but to believe as
well Maurice broke I he's the I know he
was one of the one of the most famous
scientists in biology and he he
converted to Islam because of all this
he was that French sign but he's the
French scientist yeah and he converted
to Islam he's written a book the Quran
the Bible on science and I mean these
are these are facts that are bringing
not just you know like you say in your
show sometimes car mechanics they aren't
to bring those kind of people to Islam
but real intellectual people who were
sincere are now coming toward Islam
because they realize there's not really
a way this could have been written by I
mean no matter how smart this man was
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him
there's no way you could have known that
there's no way he could have known that
you're figuring this out you're using
your mind you're taking a scientific
analytical approach and we're going to
come back to hear more with our brother
Omar we'll be right back he's the lead
coming to the truth requires two things
that requires deep thinking that you've
already done but it requires another
step and that's courage if you have the
truth but you don't have courage you
won't stand up for the truth and that's
as good as standing up for falsehood I
would say this thing that you're just
told thing it's not in the scripture and
they would say a marginal note added by
scribe yeah okay we know that and I'd be
thinking if you know this is not the
Bible why are you preaching it as if
it's gospel truth that's from hunger
I am not afraid to stand alone I am not
afraid to stand alone if a las vacas I i
am not afraid to stand alone i am not
afraid to stand alone it's a las vacas i
am not afraid to stand alone i am not
afraid to stand alone i am not afraid to
stand back here on the Dean show with
our brother Omar who is coming up in a
Muslim family not practicing but you
have some of the moral teachings some of
the things the basics don't drink don't
fornicate you got to get married don't
smoke basic things but now you're
telling yourself why am I going to
follow these rules let me try to look
into Islam just because I can find some
contradictions there's i save the second
find some inaccuracies I can prove and
put it in the same basket as all the
other man-made religions so then i can
let loose and my conscience won't be
eating away at me right but your finest
I now it's different that so you left
off now that you are intellectually
analytically coming at this and you're
finding out that this is not the case it
is coming more so to fruition that this
is something that could possibly be from
the crater are you there yet that it's a
hundred percent where you at now I'm
there yet I mean yes I'm there but I'm
challenging it still you know because
I'm trying to think there has to be an
explanation right and I'm trying to
challenge it and one of the things that
brought me into the religion even more
is that this challenge that I was posing
to people you know all sort of people of
knowledge people just the common folk
anyone this challenging always was
actually welcomed and it was encouraged
a lot of other faiths you know I don't
mean to pick on anyone in particular but
I know a lot of other faiths say well
don't challenge it just believe it
blindly follow it
no and don't question it because if you
question it then you're stupid you know
just believe it and I think well if
there really is a religion from God you
have to be able to question it and it
has to be undefeatable right so I'm
continuing on unquestioning these things
I'm trying to find explanations for how
these you know facts could have been put
in this book i'm trying to find maybe
this these these verses these scientific
facts they meant something else i'm just
trying to disprove it you know but every
single time i tried to just prove one of
these facts I actually get bombarded
with more evidence that it's it's the
truth you know and so but you mentioned
something earlier that you hoped and
thought that you were sincere that you
were you know you were trying to do this
but at the same time were you being
sincere about it you weren't like even
if it was a truth you weren't trying to
cover it up no no I no absolutely not I
was never trying to cover everything up
or you know I never just put the book
away and said I'm sure it's a fluke you
know this never happened i'm just trying
to and even to this day I still do that
you're challenging but is are you
sincere at the same time absolutely
absolutely I'm you know our religion
teach just too if we find something
better we go to it so if i find that the
quran was actually written you know 20
years ago then i go away from Islam you
know that isn't the case and so even to
this day so you're not finding anything
better no I cannot find anything better
no and I and I look into I mean I've
looked into scientific facts of the
Bible I've looked into how the Bible
plays into you know modern day I look
into how I mean I lived in Japan for
three years I've already Buddhism
intensively and Buddhism it's nice and
all that but there's no there's no
evidence and that's the kind of person I
am I need evidence I need proof to to
believe in something you know you go and
buy a car right you don't buy it because
the sales man tells you to buy it you
buy it because you've done the research
and you have the evidence that this is
the best car for you why should be lit
and being different so you look like you
looked into Buddhism you looked into
some of the other religions also yeah
Christian I mean I have a lot of
Christian friends you know I looked into
Judaism
looked into I mean religions that you
probably would never even heard of you
know in in Japan because I was there for
three years and I'm just trying to find
and a lot of religions preach good you
know I'm not saying that Islam is the
only religion that's you know good I
mean Christianity is good you know do
one to your neighbor who you want done
to yourself you know it's these are all
good but you know you don't have to have
a religion to be good and so if I'm
going to follow a religion I don't want
to be a Muslim dish because as long as
good because every religion is good you
know what what makes Islam different
from everything else that's my question
and that's why I research everything did
you find that when you look at these
other religions because they can teach
some good but if the foundation that is
built on it's not from the create or
that hold on it could be teaching you to
do some some good but if you look at
some of these other religions for
instance they may call to be good to
your neighbor they might call to give in
charity but if the ultimate evil is to
set up another God besides God may God
into a man or his creation then
ultimately this can't be from God
because no the message has always been
the same worship the One God not his
creation so if these other religions for
instance are calling you to worship
Buddha or a man or a woman or an ID or a
saint then that's contradicting the way
of life of God did you how did you
that's one thing I noticed too i mean
almost every religion seems to be based
off AI mean a lot of muslims we know
this and a lot of times we say this i'm
just going to say it again a lot of most
religions seem to be based on a person
or a place you know I mean Christianity
Christ right Buddhism Buddha Hinduism
the Hindus valleys you know yes yeah i
mean i'm trying to think you know but
islam isn't I mean what does Islam mean
I mean since their submission doesn't
want to created you sincere submissions
it was a great addition thorn and these
are all by definition this is how we can
say that Islam has been here since the
very beginning of time since the very
big very gate before that even before
that I'll even say before that even
because everything the this cup is in
some serious omission to the one who
created it because it's following the
rules of gravity is following the rules
of physics that second eyes everywhere
everything is and will the Sun the Sun
everything you know I met a guy who
worship the sun the other day yeah
speaking understand the different story
but I just thought that was kind of
funny because you're going to worship
this done this phone is going to die one
day then how's it going to save you yeah
ok so now tell us because we don't have
too much time we want to get all the
great highlights of your life that now
you're coming to this realization that
this is from the crater right so what
happens now you're young and you know
and a lot of people who maybe they might
know this but they don't follow it up
with action and janeshia how did you go
from here well change doesn't happen
overnight you know I mean even though i
was now starting to realize that there
is just not a way i could understand how
this book can be from a man has to be
from God I said fine but you know I
still want to do this other stuff so
I'll be religious when I come home but
then when I go out you know I'll do the
other stuff too for not living the best
of both worlds right and for a while
that's that's how that's how it you know
was but then I think what really started
to change was the establishing of the
prayer because this is when you are in
direct communication with God no no no
intermediaries you know no not going
through a man to God no detours just
right I'm talking to God directly you
start just implement just the right
money and and it's not again this is not
an overnight thing I mean first it was
just one prayer day right and it wasn't
you know only in my apartment i'm not
going to pray outside of you know my
apartment the safety and the comfort and
that's fine for a beginner you know I
don't have any regrets about that
because that's how you ease into you
know your real calling but so it was
just once you know once a day and then
during Ramadan ok now it's time to be
really religious maybe I'll do it two
times a day maybe three if I'm you know
in the mood and eventually you just keep
doing this and you keep doing this and
you memorize what you have to say and
you memorize the movements and it just
becomes so easy it becomes so and it
feels so natural you know it's not it's
not embarrassing someone looks at you
when you're praying it's easy to see
this man is praying you know we don't
have any kind of you don't shake our
arms all around and
do some healthy weird nothing weird
frustrating putting your head on the
ground right the same way that Jesus did
when he fell on his face and prayed to
God Moses Abraham although there so we
as far as we know the prophets prayed
like this so and so you started to
implement the prayer and you started
slowly little by little and then you
worked up to what five times a day then
five times while number the first day i
prayed five times a day it was a big
deal you know cuz now I felt okay now
i'm a real Muslim you know and so I
prayed five times a day for three days
in a row and I'm like okay now I need a
break now I'll pray three times today
and he just kind of you know you make
these schedules for yourself and
everyone will ease into it at their own
pace but eventually the more I began to
pray the more I was willing to pray
outside of the comfort of my own
apartment you know and now i'm praying
not on the street but i'm praying you
know in my place of employment i'm
praying at school and people start to
see you and you become more conscious of
it you know and the more conscious of
your muslim self you become the more you
want to learn about it you know the more
you want to understand yourself because
you know people are judging you whether
maybe it's good maybe it's bad you know
whatever and so this is where i became
more and more interested in the study of
my own faith and I'm telling you just
the more I studied it the more I just
became committed you know sometimes
people they study their religion and
they learn more and more about it but as
far as making less my stance and so they
say well I'm this religion but I really
believe it you know with me it's
everything was in sync the more I
understood the more I understood about
my body about the world about everything
you know everything just made sense the
more you learn the more you got
committed the more you started to
implement the second pillar of Islam the
salaat the prayer the more did that help
you to keep away from a lot of the bad
things of stuff that are out there yes
okay and that's what you know when I
meet some friends or even my my family
when sometimes people they just see
Islam as nothing but a simple set of
rules you know you can't do this can't
do that and then when you look at it
this way you're really starting to lose
touch of what Islam really
you know so before I tell anyone I mean
new Muslims I don't give them any rules
I just say establish the prayer yeah the
rest is going to come with time because
you're going to want to do it yourself
ya know so that's that is my first
advice to everyone I mean including
myself I remind myself every day just
pray just establish the pair because
everything else falls into place once
you build the foundation everything else
comes into place let's take another
break and be right back with our brother
Omar here on a disha doctor say to me
why have you become a Muslim no I give a
very frivolous on so i say i want to be
on the side of the angels [ __ ] is a gar
she's a number one rap artists in the
world he sold over 60 million records
worldwide seem a lien Steve million he
was a young guy we're basically
everything that somebody you would think
that life is all about he had everything
you can imagine show you're watching the
Dean Sean we're here with our brother
Omar Omar you were talking when we left
off about establishing the prayer this
is a direct connection with the creator
of the heavens and the earth before that
you got the correct knowledge you
started to see that you know what this
cannot be from a man this cannot be
written by a group of man this Quran the
verbatim word of God is from the Creator
and you started to implement what he
told you to do the connection now
because he needs the prayer he don't
need it but no as he says in the Quran
that established a prayer for my
remembrance because indeed the prayer
keeps one away from evil doings
shamelessness things that you know what
will just lead a person to corruption so
now you don't want to go to the club no
more you don't want to do some of these
things that you know what no desire for
that no I mean some people may say that
not being sincere about it but I'm too
busy you know basking in the love of a
lot to really care about that so
mashallah you said Allah now now someone
might think that's so long god or
something what do you know when you say
Allah who's Allah the God the God you
know in arabic allah means God and then
I'll means the so scholars most scholars
speculate that the word of law came from
you put al with Allah Allah
and it means the god this EV this is the
you know most UL we don't know for sure
but this is where we are most certain
this word came from Allah so it just
means the God doesn't mean you know the
Arab God doesn't mean the god of the
Muhammad you know just means the god no
nothing nothing you know strange about
that word and using Christians who are
Arabic speaking they only they also use
the word Allah to all my Christian
friends just big Arabic I say a lot and
you know what I'm talking about okay so
say hey I'm not Muslim know they say oh
yeah thank you okay so so the person
that you know what he's never heard this
term we're talking about the creator of
the son of the moon the creator of Jesus
Moses Abraham the creator of all that
exists now continue on we have just a
few more minutes what's going on with
your life now so well you can probably
like many people write a book but it's
we just crunched on time you just want
people to really be able to benefit from
these short stories of people so they
can get a little more motivated to do
the good that Islam calls are being to
do what happened what's going on now
with you well one of the biggest things
you know when you accept this way of
life is you're going to be tested and
some tests are much harder than others
and so right now I'm being tested you
know just like everyone there's many
challenges in my life and there are many
glories in my life too but everything is
everything is a test you know and so
when I'm praying at work or you know in
the mall or whatever a lot of times it
becomes very hard to gain that
motivation to let people know on Muslim
you know and I think everyone has that
kind of problem but when I one thing
that really helps me get through letting
people know and the Muslim is
remembering the life of the Prophet
peace be upon him because you know that
the Prophet I mean he was threatened
with his wife his followers oftentimes
died to protect the the message of Islam
all just by practicing you know this is
I mean the Arabs at the time of the
Prophet many of them hated them hated
him because he was trying to change
everything and so I just remember that
if the Prophet can be Judas and people
who like the Prophet can do this with
their lives being threatened I think I
can do it with people giving me a look
you know so so any closing comments and
suggestions for those out
who also the prayer established you'd
like that a threat I think that lead
that is everything you know that leads
to everything else comes from the prayer
brother establish the prayer thank you
very much thank you thank you very much
jazakallah hi may god almighty allah
reward you for being with us as well it
was well continued strong continue
forward and that was our brother Omar
who came to a point of his life and he
started to question and he questioned
the Quran he was sincere and you wanted
to see you know what can this be from a
human being if it is I'm gonna do my own
thing then I'll make up my own way of
life but he saw that you know what no no
no this Quran the verbatim word of God
is from God is from the crater so I've
got to do God's thing I better do what
the crater wants me to do so he did the
most important thing after testifying
swearing to that there's no god but God
there's no deity worthy of worship
except Allah and Muhammad is His
Messenger that includes all the message
that preceded him including Jesus Christ
Moses Abraham Noah they were on messages
of God they were calling people to
worship one God and not his creation and
then he established the prayer and this
is where many people are lacking so we
got to get motivated put your face of
the ground repent to the crater ask him
to make it easy and continue to strive
towards goodness good character develop
yourself to be the best human being that
you can be and you're only going to do
that with the craters help so ask him
beseech him to help you to help us so we
can be the best and then we can get
paradise because life is short it can
end at any time and with that set
continue to come back here to the Dean
show we also have the new radio show
it's all at vidinha show com continue to
watch the same time same Channel until
next time peace be unto you